what's going on guys this is Rob and
this bumper is to let you guys know that
we are having a Super Smash Brothers
tournament this weekend on Saturday on
the discord server if you guys don't
know about it I have a discourse server
for all the comments explained fans we
have quizzes we have all kinds of
tournaments games things for you guys to
do and once every month we actually have
a kind of vs. battle of sorts where we
give away a Rob core range so if you
guys want to be a part of that make sure
you guys check the link down in the
description it'll be a permanent link to
the discord service you'll always have
access and yeah hopefully I'll see you
there let's begin
okay so we are getting into infinity
ending and here's the funny thing
I initially plan on waiting until like
next week to start this but you guys
been screaming at me when we covered
infinity conflict to start the next part
so I was like okay I mean I don't really
see a reason not to but there's a couple
things I do want to explain here because
there was a little bit of uncertainty
that I noticed in the comments section
some of the guys seem a little unsure
and so the way this is played out so far
is we essentially had like two versions
of Thanos right we had present-day
Thanos and then we had future Thanos and
the future Thanos had somehow found a
way to essentially absorb all these
various cosmic entities right everybody
from localized and and smaller cosmic
entities like mistress death or eternity
or infinity all the way up to like the
Living Tribunal and so initially the
question was why is he working with his
younger self and the idea was that he
was guiding present-day Thanos
through a series of steps to ensure his
own survival right to ensure that he
would become the person he became vo
with regards to future Thanos and so the
result of this is that from there the
question was okay then if there's
something standing in his path then why
doesn't he stop that and this really
came into play with the death of eros
and the nature of Adam warlock in the
sense that as we talked about in the
last video Adam warlock is essentially
in world he'll always come back right no
matter how he dies and no matter how
much time passes you'll always return
this basically placed Adam warlock
outside of the norm because he does not
abide by the normal rules of life and
death
when eros was killed by Adam warlock
Adam warlock had hoped that mistress
death would banish eros from her realm
for whatever reason either because she
understood Adam warlocks goal and
killing him or because she believed that
eros was going to be working alongside
Thanos to basically use Serpa role
whatever the reason was we knew that it
was because she was afraid that eros was
working alongside Thanos she banished
eros from her realm and then in turn
landed eros outside the norm because he
now no longer abides by the normal rules
of life and death he's essentially
immortal he can never really die and so
having said this what it did is it led
up to this massive battle that was
actually kind of a little bit of a
portion that that seems a little murky
here we essentially had a scenario where
Thanos had absorbed a Living Tribunal
into himself
what makes this kind of crazy is that as
this comic picks up we've got the one
above all and then you've got the Living
Tribunal they're right so I don't know
this is some kind of an error or if I
misinterpreted it you know however it
was that happened but literally in the
preface of the book like as you open it
up and you know one of the last things
it says is like you know present-day
Thanos has killed the last embodiment
for the Living Tribunal itself and
merged with his despotic future self
right so like he absorbed the Living
Tribunal
so the question is how is the Living
Tribunal here that's really kind of how
this is now at the end of the day it
doesn't really matter because when this
happens the one above all basically
tells Thanos to stop right to stop his
actions and to in turn to go back to his
normal role and Thanos says no now the
question that a lot of people have here
and then that I noticed was a lot of
people are asking if the one above all
is this Nayan nipa tenth indestructible
an immutable force inside the entirety
of the Marvel multiverse then why
doesn't it just will Thanos out of
existence right there's nothing that one
of them all cannot do and the reason why
is because jim Starlin is basically
altering the form and function of the
one above all and stories from years
past right old Fantastic Four stories
old sensational spider-man stories the
role of the one above all was
essentially kind of a prime mover in the
sense that like he created the first
universe we saw that in Al Ewing's
Ultimates and in the first universe
basically fractured when the aspirins
and the Celestials went to war and then
those fractured pieces created the first
multiverse and by whatever manner and
whatever means those different universes
came to an end and then were reborn
again but the one above all didn't
really sit back and then like create the
first multiverse and then every time a
universe dies he creates a new one he
just sort of set things in motion and
they went through whatever path they
went through but regardless of his hands
on or or lack of lack thereof his hands
on approached with the multiverse the
reality was there's nothing that one
above all cannot do he represents the
riders or the artists or Stanley or Jack
Kirby what you have a depiction you want
to go with depending on which comic
you're reading at the time jim Starlin
is basically modifying that and what he
says here is this idea that the the one
above all is actually not really a slave
to the structure of the multiverse but
he can't break its rules that the one
above all basically created all things
in existence and there are certain
safeguards there that not even the one
above all can can get passed which
really kind of defies his purpose right
it's kind of like that that old-school
quagmire can God create an object that's
too heavy for him to lift that's really
what this is right you know kind of this
idea of defying omnipotence and so
that's why it seemed a little strange
because the one above all should be able
to just will fan us out of existence
that it should just kind of end that way
but the result is that when you're
invoking something like this you can't
write you can't on one hand
the one above all and basically kind of
krytus an aria or Thanos faces off
against him in any believable way if
like the one of of all is this immutable
and indestructible force that nothing
can stop and so what happens is over the
span of the first three pages the one
above all and the end I guess The Living
Tribunal you know in this instance face
off against Thanos and Bannos
immediately absorbs them and so
essentially Thanos has now become the
new one above all and that's the crazy
thing about this right it happens like
that in the blink of an eye and it's a
wild situation because you literally
have Adam warlock and you have eros and
you have pip patrol watching this whole
thing go down and when Thanos re-emerges
Thanos is now all things in existence
from that point going forward they bail
eros grabs pip the troll he grabs Adam
warlock with the intention of
teleporting away Adam warlock Yanks his
hand away eros and pip the troll are
gone and Adam warlock remains behind and
talking to Thanos the other the new one
above all we kind of get this
explanation rather the sort of
explanation in terms of what he can do
and so on and so forth now what's also
interesting is he points out this notion
that because the fact that Adam warlock
and eros exist outside of the of the
norm that Thanos while he can detect
them has to work hard to do it right
they're not just easily perceptible to
him it's almost like it's almost like
trying to detect a dark gray amidst a
black background right it's possible you
just really have to be looking for it
and so because of that Adam warlock one
immediately picks up on that and then
two you end up having Thanos who
basically pulls Adam warlock into
himself for the purpose of always being
able to locate Adam warlock right to
kind of remove that aspect and then from
there
Thanos starts to muse and this is normal
for for jim Starlin it's actually one of
the things that always made his handling
of Thanos so cool the way he would write
Thanos was really more of he would see
himself almost kind of like in a
philosophical way right he would he
would kind of news about these things he
says now I am linked to all there is
right he's not actually I mean he is all
there is but he's linked into everything
right everything from the past and the
present throughout every single universe
that exists and is almost overwhelming
but it's almost overwhelming for Thanos
to sit down and say all actualities all
realities that exists out there every
universe that exists in the entirety of
the multiverse I am all those things
this is a whole new level of power
that's way beyond anything that has ever
had before the closest he ever got to
this was during Marvel the end when he
absorbed the multiverse into himself and
then brought it back with death
basically being permanent meaning nobody
could be resurrected
it was kind of a criticism of Marvel in
the sense that they always killed and
brought back people and to basically
kind of remove that or trying to make it
in continuity Marvel ultimately said no
because they like being able to kill
people and then bring them back later it
makes for good clickbait storytelling
what it does show here is really kind of
the role of the one above all in terms
of all the various forms that it exists
in and when it comes to the one above
all in Marvel it's one of these things
were like it's it's Marvel's version of
the presence from DC and the presence is
like DC's version of the one above all
right and what I mean by that is what
you have inside of the comic book
landscape you have a singular universe
then you have stuff like an over verse
or you have an under verse so on and so
forth but the fun of the the broad broad
strokes here that you have a singular
universe then you have a multiverse and
then you have what's called the
omniverse
and the way this works is that a
universe is a universe right it's just a
singular universe that you occupy the
main male universe the ultimate universe
the Marvel Cinematic Universe those
those different universes make up the
entirety of the multiverse the omniverse
is composed of all things in existence
right so there's the Marvel multiverse
in the DC multiverse in the spawn
multiverse and like like any concept
that exists out there it's part of the
greater omniverse and Marvel's one above
all it's kind of a guy who oversees all
that right as Marvel's God above all
gods essentially so is one of these
things were they all kind of crossover
and all gets really weird and it's not
really designed to say that like the one
above all is over the presents it's
Marvel kind of saying I mean our version
is and then DC's like no our version is
and spawns like no no you're both wrong
our version is so it's it's kind of one
of these things where it just sort of
goes around but Thanos is basically
tapping into you and overseeing
everything across every single universe
in every single multiverse on every
single property that exists in the world
belonging to anybody regardless of
whoever made it that's how far-reaching
this is and so it gets kind of crazy
here because with that being the case
heroes kind of picks up on the notion of
what we talked about already that Thanos
cannot easily recognize him because he's
outside the norm Thanos has to hunt for
him as hard as he possibly can right a
needle in a stack of needles is really
what this is and so would that be in the
case because pip the troll is
essentially viewed as Thanos as one of
the people out there who can throw a
wrench in the works then what the eros
does is basically tear up a backpack
more or less and then put the troll
inside of it so that pip the troll is as
close to eros as you can possibly be and
by extension of eros being out
the norm that will hopefully kind of
permeate to hit the troll now it really
kind of seems to be this idea that it's
not really like an arrow shaped hole in
the universe if that makes sense almost
kind of like a permeation of like this
energy that makes him outside the norm
that hopefully will also encompass
encompassed pip the troll that kind of
seems to be what he's shooting for and
jim Starlin plays it fast and loose we
don't really get any definitive answers
there but we're kind of more or less
left to believe that is actually the
case and so what is up happening is is
eros and pip the troll basically say
okay fine then let's see what's going on
let's see if we can find a way to defeat
the annals in the past or whatever it is
kind of throwing out these various
MacGuffins here and you end up having
eros and pip the troll show up on the
ship of Thanos which is currently
occupied by Corvus glaive and Proxima
midnight but then they vanish they
disappear and eros figures out this is
happening because what Thanos is doing
is getting rid of anybody who knows his
plan and who could potentially find a
way to take him out that's what's so
cool about this if Stannis is just kind
of getting rid of people here in there
but this is the one thing to understand
here and this is this is awesome the way
jim Starlin does it Thanos is handling
his omnipotence and his power the way on
mortal person would Thanos is not
handling his abilities the way the one
above all would and there's a huge
distinction there we'll find out what
that distinction is as we get through
this video but from there you pick up
with Adam warlock who basically emerges
after having been ensnared by Thanos
with Danis ability to see him and
essentially locates came to conquer now
again came to conquer was from a
previous infinity story but it was by
virtue of K in the Conqueror that eros
managed to attain his time-traveling
technology as well as a few other things
going on but what this means is that
using the ability of King to manipulate
time Adam warlock seemingly has some bit
of an out and so from here we jump to
one of the most important parts of the
story
when we pick up with present-day Thanos
and present-day Thanos his consciousness
is basically inside the mind of future
Thanos right like this version of Thanos
that merged with the one above all and
all that kind of stuff that's future
Thanos who's done all that present-day
Thanos is just kind of a consciousness
that's along for the ride and it's cool
when he basically talks about this right
he says things like yes I'm so here like
you know always always basically press
gained into the situation but what it
shows is that their ideologies are not
entirely linked present-day Thanos is
not fully onboard with what future
Thanos is doing but he knows his plan he
knows what he wants to achieve but even
for modern-day Thanos
that seems pretty extreme and that says
something right given whatever this
future plan
whatever this plan of future Thanos is
if present-day Thanos looks at that and
says yeah man like that's pretty crazy
man like that's pretty extreme that
means just really got to be something
right because we're talking about a guy
who got ahold of the Infinity Gauntlet
and wiped out half the life in the
universe just to impress a girl right so
like it's kind of crazy like it's kind
of not stealing in terms of this this
whole thing going but what it also shows
here and really what he what he
basically tells us is that the amount of
energy and the amount of focus necessary
to be able to handle this much power
while it's within the abilities of
future Thanos to contain these abilities
it's a whole other thing to understand
how to use them effectively and so what
this means is that future Thanos is
still figuring out what it is that he
can do he hasn't fully been able to
channel the totality of the one above
all his power now this is important
because what it means is that it
presents this idea that maybe even the
one above all was limited by its own
imagination and that if Thanos can
essentially break free of those
limitations then his power would
transcend the previous one above alls
power the reality of this is that what
future Thanos is doing is hunting around
for eros it's the thing that's
dominating his mind and the reason why
is because eros will in some former
fashion find a way to basically defeat
future Thanos right like eros could find
a way to defeat his brother it's
possibly only a matter of time before
Thanos loses this power of the one above
all so again it's super cool it's a guy
with the power of God who hasn't quite
figured out how to use it all yet and so
from there you basically pick up with
eros who's like okay one he asked Isaac
the sentient computer right before it's
destroyed my future Thanos if he can
figure out a way to calculate when the
universe is going to end and they're
able to you know he's able to basically
draw you know kind of create an
algorithm you know in the blink of an
eye like super advanced you know
otherworldly computers do and then
essentially calculate when the universe
is going to end and when eros and piff
the troll are teleported there it's just
a giant empty canvas and then future
Thanos simply says let there be an end
in essence Thanos destroys himself the
idea behind this and this is what's
really important here the idea behind
this is that Thanos you know with what
these limitations that were created by
the one above all the indication is that
Thanos is still bound by those and so
what this really seems to point out is
that the future version of Thanos his
goal after having basically defeated
eros and ensuring that nobody can be in
his way is to basically wipe out
everything in existence and then
recreated as himself being the one about
he's wiping the board clean and starting
over again it removes any of the
limitations that were created by the
previous one above all and thousands is
free to recreate all the multiverse and
the omniverse as he sees fit and that's
what's so wild here it's because what we
do from there is where eros and pit
Patrol or essentially dispelled from
that future and sit back to the modern
day what it does you know because of the
fact that they cannot die right so like
they're just kick back to the modern day
what it does is it picks up with came to
conquer and Adam warlock having a
discussion with each other and came to
conquer not really wanting to
essentially admits that what deal the
the kind of field that he's on right now
with Thanos attaining the power of the
one above all with the actions of Adam
warlock things like that these are way
beyond what King is normally used to and
the reality is he's basically being
reduced to a guy who could just help
Adam warlock out as best he can despite
all the intelligence and all the
time-traveling abilities of kang hwi's
way out of his element here more so than
that Adam warlock throws in this idea
and really kind of gives us some this
amazing notion that future Thanos
operating with all this power again who
has not figured out how to use it and in
the time that he could be taking to
figure out how to use it instead he's
taking that time to focus on finding
eros this makes him vulnerable this is
basically just a really really really
powerful Thanos and that's why we don't
really have an instance where it's like
well why did you just go back to the
very beginnings of time and stop heroes
from being born if Thanos went back in
time and killed eros at birth then
perhaps future Thanos never exists it is
really kind of bound by the rules of
time right the rules of time travel time
manipulation different things like that
and so what we end up doing is picking
up with Adam warlock right Adam warlock
basically trying to find a particular
access point within the cosmos basically
an access point what that will allow him
to enter the psyche of future Thanos
right because he's undetectable or at
least it seemed to be that way and then
like entering the future psyche if
Thanos and then in turn you know just
kind of getting a better understanding
of what's going on now the reason why
Adam warlock is able to do this is not
because he's undetectable that's my
mistake he is but the reason why Adam
warlock can do this is because Adam
warlock is part and partial to Thanos
and so Thanos won't really feel it is
like an ant biting him or anything like
that he'll just kind of see it as the
normal comings and goings of the
multiverse and how things function and
so on and so forth and because his
attention is off of Adam warlock because
he believes that Adam warlock is now a
negated factor right he's not in
anything to really worry about instead
he with him focusing on eros
please Adam warlock open to invade the
psyche of Thanos because he's just not
paying attention but before Adam warlock
can do that he suddenly met by the
arrival of an unexpected character who
that character is we'll find out in the
next video that being said guys we're
gonna bring this for you to an end
cliffhangers if you are new here to come
as explained make sure you guys at the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]